-As excited as people are
to see someone
from "Game of Thrones" --
the show is so loved --
I feel like you have been
on the other side of fandom.
You are a huge Madonna fan.
Is this true?
-Yeah.
-This is a lifelong adoration?
-Yeah, since I was 8 years old.
-8 years old.
And I used to dress up
as Madonna in my bedroom,
and I would try to copy
the dance routines,
and I would be doing
my Madonna look.
I´d borrow my mother´s makeup.
I mean, I´d really go there.
-Yeah.
-I´d go there on the look.
And it was a lifelong passion,
you know?
-And you recently
just got to see this --
was this the first time
you´d seen her in concert or --
-This was the very first time
I´d ever seen Madonna
in concert.
And I was in Australia.
I was filming "Top of the Lake."
So I was in Sydney
with my dear friend Alfie Allen
from "Game of Thrones."
-Yes, Theon Greyjoy.
-And I said to him, "Come on.
Get us tickets to Madonna,"
which he did,
and I was very excited.
And on the day of the concert,
I was at home.
I got a text --
I got that familiar "ding"
of a text message on the phone.
-Uh-huh. Sure.
-And I looked at the phone,
and the message said,
"Hi, Gwendoline.
This is Guy Oseary,
Madonna´s manager.
I understand you´re coming
to the gig tonight."
-Is there a way
to text in this voice?
´Cause I love it.
[ Laughter ]
I want all my texts -- Yeah.
-This is how
this particular text sounded.
-Yes, okay, great.
-Exactly that exact intonation.
-Uh-huh.
-And it said, "I hear you´re --
I hear you´re coming
to the gig tonight" --
continuing voice.
[ Laughter ]
"Fancy jumping onstage with M?
She´s a fan."
-Wow.
[ Audience cheers ]
-I cried.
-You cried?
[ Laughter ]
-I cried.
-Did you cry --
Did you cry right away,
or was it
one of those slow cries,
where you were like,
"Oh, I´m not going to"?
-Do you know what?
I look at it, and it was --
like, it was so involuntary --
the mouth opened,
then the slow wail of "Ahhhhhh!"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-And here we have proof.
-[ Laughs ]
-There you are onstage with her.
So, there you are.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And so...
-Yeah.
-...did you have
any responsibilities
onstage with Madonna?
-I did, indeed.
I mean, I went to the concert.
So, I went to the concert.
I was in the car --
I was in the car with Alfie
slowly becoming mute
and physically paralyzed...
-Yeah. Sure.
-...through fear -- abject fear.
I arrive. We´re there.
I´m mute.
I´m just standing very quietly,
and Alfie´s saying,
"Are you okay? Are you okay?"
I´m like, "Yeah, I´m fine.
Yeah, I´m fine."
[ Laughter ]
Madonna appears,
and I start screaming so loudly,
I think my lungs are going to
come out of my mouth.
Alfie is saying,
"Babe, I know you´re excited,
but can you calm down a bit?"
[ Laughter ]
Madonna starts doing
"Borderline."
She´s alongside us.
She´s playing the guitar.
I´m screaming.
She looks down and winks
and renders me silent.
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
She winked you --
She made you --
-She winked at me, I was silent,
and then the screaming
started again.
-Oh, my God.
[ Light laughter ]
-So they came up to me, and they
said, "Okay, are you ready?
You´re going to go
up onstage now."
This is for a segment
for Madonna´s song called
"Unapologetic Bitch."
-Uh-huh.
-And part of my time
between receiving
the text message
and going to the concert,
I´d watched this segment
on YouTube
and rehearsed the choreography,
because I didn´t want to make
a fool of myself
in front of Madonna.
[ Laughter ]
-Of course not.
-I was practicing
alone in my apartment.
-Yeah.
-Practicing.
That´s Madonna there.
I´m undulating at Madonna.
So -- So, then it happens,
and they say, "Are you ready?"
And I --
And I sort of go, "Ah."
-Yeah.
-I just make that noise -- "Ah,"
because there are 22,000 people
in the auditorium.
-Sure.
-And then they gave me
a gentle push.
Performance mode kicked in.
Those three years
of classical training, Seth...
-Yeah, they paid off.
-Well, for that moment.
-And it looks like here
you´re screaming
and holding two bananas.
Is that accurate?
[ Laughter ]
And let me just say --
this is exactly what I wanted
the image of you onstage
with Madonna to be.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
The mouth.
-Yeah.
-The mouth is open so wide.
The jaw had unhinged
like a snake.
-Well,
just congratulations on that,
and congratulations
on "Top of the Lake,"
such a fantastic show.
Jane Campion --
an incredible director.
Elisabeth Moss --
your wonderful costar.
-Yeah.
-I really enjoyed
the first episode.
Thank you so much
for being here.
So great to see you again.
-Thank you, Seth.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Gwendoline Christie, everybody!